le docteur l'école 17 lapidoux l'a
reconnu mais pub et raymond barnabé n'a
jamais accepté la mort de son frère d'un
chocolat chaud
j'ai beaucoup de difficulté à vivre avec
le même 25 ans plus tard demeure la
mémoire surtout des frustrations que son
frère richard chauffeur de taxi a été
arrêté devant sa maison
à laval on soupçonnait richard barnabé
d'avoir fracassé la vitre d'une église
les policiers ont eu de la difficulté à
le maîtriser
il est ressorti du poste 44 dans un coma
et respect par lui-même mais son cerveau
est finie le père de famille avait subi
de multiples fractures aux côtes et au
visage
en plus d'un arrêt cardiaque qui l'a
laissé dans un état neurovégétatif
jusqu'à sa mort en 1996
c'est une chose terrible ce qui arrive
puis on veut pas que ça se reproduise
aujourd'hui son frère qui était aussi
policier à l'époque ne comprend pas
pourquoi les policiers impliqués dans
cette affaire ont pu continuer leur
travail malgré leur casier judiciaire
en 1995
quatre policiers ont été reconnus
coupables de voies de fait ayant causé
des lésions
pierre bergeron et lui samson ont écopé
de 3 mois d'emprisonnement et ont été
destitués
mais par la suite ils ont été réintégrés
au sein du service de police pour leur
part les policiers andré lapointe et
michel vadeboncoeur ont reçu une peine
de deux mois d'emprisonnement et de 180
heures de travaux communautaires
depuis cet événement aucun détenu est
amené au poste de quartier ils sont
plutôt dirigés vers les centres
opérationnels la pose de caméras à
l'intérieur des centres opérationnels
il ya eu des façons de procéder
différentes pour la fouille des
personnes les personnes qui est en état
de crise il ya plein de choses
continuent en place depuis 7h cet
événement la mairesse aucun membre pour
un service d'envergure que les services
de police à vélo montréal ça faisait une
tache noire au service ici 40 bastien
radio canada montréal